mutation has become a sort of genetic
boogeyman it's a common trope in horror
in people mutations caused disfigurement
aggression even cannibalism so it's not
surprising that the conversation around
mutation and the virus that causes kovat
19 feels scary the genetic mutations in
real life aren't like the ones we see in
movies and on a viral level they could
actually help us track and manage kovat
19 so let's break down what mutations
actually are and what they could mean
for the virus we're facing right now
this is SARS Co v2 the virus that causes
kovat 19 it's a type of RNA virus some
of which mutate practically every time
they replicate SARS Co v2 is actually
one of the rare RNA viruses that has a
proofreading mechanism that slows down
its mutation rate zone despite that it
has mutated and it will continue to
mutate but that's not as scary as it
sounds it's basically a typo or a
mistake that occurs like if you were
writing an essay Tsarskoe v2 s RNA is
basically a blueprint for making more
Tsarskoe v2 s but viruses can't
replicate themselves they have to hack
into another organism cells and use
their machinery to make new copies
here's how that process works the virus
will like let its unita kotero
free into the cytoplasm of this out and
then when that genetic material
encounter it's called a ribosome the
ribosome reads the virus's blueprint and
starts building a new virus then it'll
read it three nucleic acids at a time so
we call it a codon and there are always
three nucleic acids and a combination of
three nucleic acids corresponds to a
single amino acid string those amino
acids together and that's what creates
the proteins but occasionally the wrong
nucleic acid will get added to the chain
this can sometimes but not always lead
to changes down the line making that
offspring virus slightly different from
its parent each amino acid or
combination of amino acids
is responsible for defining some
characteristic of the virus things like
its shape how infectious it is what kind
of organism it infects and the types of
cells it targets so a mutation or more
likely multiple mutations has the
potential to change any of those things
theoretically everything is fair game
because these you know mutations are
totally random events but a mutation in
a single virus only affects that one
virus for a mutation to stick it has to
be able to be passed on to new
generations and new hosts so something
that messes with vital functions like
the virus's ability to replicate means a
dead end
in terms of the virus's fitness the
probability of beneficial neutral and
harmful mutations shifts based on the
environment it's in let's say a virus is
perfectly suited to its environment the
virus doesn't stop mutating but it would
be impossible for a mutation to make it
even more perfect so the likelihood of
mutations that are neutral or harmful
for the virus are very high it's
impossible to say star as Co v2 is
perfectly suited for infecting humans
but since it can move from person to
person so efficiently experts don't
think it's facing a lot of pressure to
adapt plus its two most concerning
characteristics how contagious it is and
how harmful it can be are controlled by
multiple genes so in order to become
more contagious or more harmful the
virus would need to undergo multiple
beneficial mutations at exactly the
right time that's just not very likely
but Mary points out that even talking
about mutations in terms of dangerous or
worse can be subjective in my mind what
makes this outbreak or this epidemic
especially concerning is that so many
people who get infected with the virus
don't really show symptoms and that's
why it's being able to sprint so far but
if there were to be a change that you
know meets the virus the infection much
worse than people in some ways would be
easier to control so there are all these
different trade-offs we need to think
about mutations can actually be pivotal
when it comes to fighting kovat 19 since
we know what Sarah's Co V 2's genome
looked like at the
beginning of the outbreak we can track
when and where it changes we actually
saw that patients that we identified in
Connecticut in the early stages of the
outbreak here their virus was more
closely related to viruses that were
collected and sequenced in Washington
State
compared to in China or in Europe for
example so that actually tells us that
we have domestic transmission going on
and we are getting all this information
based off of mutations that are arisen
in the virus there are a couple
initiatives that are tracking this data
globally right now
one being next strain an open source
project that tracks the spread and
evolution of infectious diseases in
real-time right now it's focused on
kovat 19 researchers can use that
information to answer questions like how
fast is it mutating not very is it
spreading by air travel definitely
especially early on will it mutate in a
way that makes a potential vaccine
ineffective like the flu people who
design vaccines think about this all
it's like this is something that is
factored into vaccine design so
typically vaccines they use these highly
conserved targets so they'll pick some
part of the virus that is not tolerant
to to a lot of change or to do if you're
really any change it can't really mutate
away from the vaccine without you know
compromising some other really crucial
element of its life cycle plus the flu
is unique in the way its genetic
material is structured it's an RNA virus
too but its genome is segmented the
coronavirus genome is not the segments
translate to a bunch of different
proteins so every time the body sees a
new protein it has to make an entirely
different set of antibodies specifically
designed to fight it we don't know
exactly how often a new vaccine for
kovat 19 will be necessary but we do
know the virus doesn't have this same
flexibility when it comes to proteins
and experts have been looking at another
coronavirus the one that causes SARS to
get an idea of how we might handle this
one immunity to that virus lasts roughly
two to three years since it and the new
coronavirus share
a significant amount of genetic material
this could be a good estimate if that's
the case then a vaccine should last just
as long since the virus is mutating so
slowly and that's really the point
the viral ancestor of Tsarskoe v2 did
have to mutate in order to jump from
animals to people but it most likely
happened very gradually with a series of
mutations over the course of many many
years the timescale is really what
matters here I think the day we need to
be thinking about how best we can
control this outbreak in the US and also
around the world
because if there's you know no ongoing
transmission there's no mutations and
then we really have to worry